well he's here
hello
hello there's
someone who isn't even looking for the
restaurant is
fine because he's in berlin he's
fine
good morning I told you we were
already planning a wedding but there are more
things I have to tell you
[Music] does
anyone remember  that he couldn't
stay because of the sun visa and I
know that the options
ran out a year ago more or less
that's why we went to Agua and here
[Music]
and we went to get married
no if he didn't get married
but  like that with nothing, nothing, without witnesses, with
nothing, just people from the street who
paid him 20 dollars
[Music]
and from there and he talked to me, he talked, he talked to me and
convinced me until I told
him well, that's it, but we only do it because
we have papers and we  let's go
there alone knot and that's how we did
[Music]
now that Evelyn got married that she did
n't tell me that I'm her mom is something
that I can't get out of my astonishment
wedding anniversary they even have
[Music]
and this month
[  Music]
on June
1 tell me
that there should be  He told me and
the country
I don't understand why they kept it a
secret
[Music]